[Music]
all right what's this hinge audio is
this
is this what you sent all right why are
you pulling this up again just to remind
you all right cash sent this in a shower
thought i recently had was having you in
the shower right with me
and i was really
going into your [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's so sick dude that guy's never
said anything dirty as in in his entire
life how many [ __ ]
that phrase up that bad i was really
going into your [ __ ] how many women
chuckled and just matched him
purely off of i gotta know yeah i want
you going into my [ __ ] oh yeah would
you go into my [ __ ] tell me over the
voicemail like the british way to say
that yeah i'm going into your [ __ ] yeah
it's gone on long enough now that's
enough with the mouth that's how i've
gone into your [ __ ] yeah man you've not
you've sucked me off too long now
it's time we've go into your [ __ ] yeah
what do you do to a [ __ ] yeah you go in
it
what are you supposed to do to a [ __ ]
you go into it right go in it go in it
okay
i'm really going into it i push inside
it i'm certified inside your [ __ ] yeah
that'll be a good one out of context
yeah
let's hear it again i gotta hear it
again it was just too good yeah a shower
thought i recently had was having you in
the shower right with me
and i was really
going into your [ __ ]
i was really
like he couldn't believe it i was really
going into your [ __ ]
she was so sick
it was for real dude and you were right
with me
it's not like you let me do it by myself
you didn't just hand it off to me no you
were there you were like you were there
with your [ __ ] and i got to go in it i
was really going in it really going into
it
that is a [ __ ] alien yeah seriously
like
he blinked like like horizontally
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
he just finished eating a bag of worms
and then just a shower thought i
recently had
was you in the shower with me right and
you were right with me and i was really
going into your [ __ ]
fellas i want you to say that tonight or
ladies i want you to tell your
significant other verbally be like babe
i had a sex dream last night yeah yeah
yeah and say that [ __ ] verbatim was it
really about me yeah you were right
there with me oh i was yeah you were
right with me and i was really
going in your [ __ ]
oh
yeah what do you mean going
like you finished in in it or
i mean it wasn't there yet
i very well could have
but i actually went inside it but i went
in
i got into it no say let's say nothing
else just stare and smile proud of
yourself yeah
and i really
went into your [ __ ]
oh well that's good
yeah that is what sex is
so i'm glad that that part happened
yeah i was too
anyways just a shower thought yeah
anyways
anyways bye
i'm trying to see man i thought i had
like a
a [ __ ] another meme edit tick tock i
think this is gonna kill you right here
do you [ __ ] with dr pepper
me yeah that's a real question that's a
real question yeah of course i love it
i'm trying to dr purple [ __ ] what it is
[Laughter]
you just chug the whole thing by the way
they could be stronger
and it's not
trying to dock the purple [ __ ] it is
[Laughter]
gonna be stronger
it's not
[Laughter]
they could be stronger
i'm trying to dock the purple [ __ ]
let's get one more
for good measure
his lungs are on fire
[Laughter]
those burps that is filled with foam
yeah
[Laughter]
just such a distinct sound
that's why men in the 70s sounded like
that they're just drinking beer
[Laughter]
that forklift
could be strong i mean could be stronger
like like like stronger taste no i think
like the the carbonation or something
he wants more
maybe he's just done a bunch
you've seen the ones with that kid that
like chugs lacroix
yeah yeah and it like runs into his
garage yeah classics i watched the dude
so funny chugging a cold soda water you
saw this god it's so funny it puts like
the three red bulls in sorry to cut you
off the three red bulls in the [ __ ]
boot and just
no haven't seen that yeah but i mean i
love red bull so
yeah
surprise that was you who made the tick
tock yeah there's a shower thoughts
subreddit can you go there yeah i want
to read a couple of these parents pay
money to have their children put under
pressure in school so they can earn
enough money and put their children
through the same ringer
deep dom we really do live in a society
poignant
is that the word poignant if you own a
nuclear bunker wait wait read that
second one nearly everyone values a
human life
over the life of a fish
but a few people value a single human
life
over the life of every fish meaning
everyone has a certain number of fish
that they would prefer to be alive over
steve from work see that's a [ __ ]
shower thought yeah
that is a shower thought i don't give a
[ __ ] about a fish's life no
that's why you know watch when you watch
the deadliest catch it's just so
satisfying exactly
it's considered tab
sorry it's considered less taboo to
constantly pump yourself full of a
liquid stimulant drug to keep yourself
awake throughout the day rather than
laying down for a quick midday nap
yeah so
coffee
versus actual sleep
also [ __ ] google has a nap room it
does yeah i'd be in that [ __ ] eight
hours a day every day i know right
and you can get massages there too that
that's what was always funny to me about
when we'd go to lunch at work
because you'd always be like i gotta go
back i gotta work
and i always laugh i'm like nah this is
where you get the man back just look at
my watch i'm like i gotta work i'm
dragging this yeah hour and a half let
me get caught yeah i'm doing this so
someone says something yeah my favorite
[ __ ] was because i lived across the
street i'd always cut out
and i get away with it some days because
i lived across the street from full
screen yeah i would i would dip it like
three sometimes yeah
but it'd be
rebel dude bad ass bro but then it was
bad when my boss would ping me at 5 30.
hey you got a meeting but oh i'm just
taking a [ __ ]
be right there
i actually had someone make a joke to me
that was like definitely hr
reportable
so after my boss left to this little
going going-away dinner
and one of the people we worked with
was like you live across the street
right yeah she's like yeah
i used to joke with anna that uh you
know
you probably were never even here half
the time you're probably just at home
jacking off
there's a woman who said that to me what
yeah and she was cackling and she
thought it was so funny and i was like
funny it was funny
i was like i mean it's inappropriate i
was like ha
yo
yo
what the [ __ ] and she wasn't even
it wasn't like some flirty type of thing
she just thought that was a good bit
she thought and then she said she
followed she's like yeah you're a
comedian right
you
you're
it yeah yeah yeah like definitely trying
to cover yeah i'm like you two were
joking about me beating i mean
it is it's a truth
the truth but
you imagine that how sad that it is
three o'clock in the afternoon not your
truth yeah it's my truth yeah
just leaving work early and going home
just [ __ ]
just sad you should truth that oh yeah
let me truth that out real quick
sometimes you used to leave work early
to jack off